cake boss star buddy valastro built an
estimated 10 million dollar baking
empire
and right at the height of his fame a
freak and gruesome accident
has now put his career in jeopardy so
how is buddy doing today
let's find out buddy how are you doing
uh i'm feeling good you know i feel like
i'm in good spirits trying to look at
the
uh glass half full versus half empty the
positives i
still have my hands right so we're
thinking day by day and kick by cake
i had a really bad accident the other
day at my house my hand
it's been eight weeks since buddy got
his hand stuck in a broken pin setter
paled repeatedly by a metal rod for five
minutes
his sons used the saw to cut through the
rod and pulled their dad free
so right now i mean look it's
realistically you know the scars have
healed up very very stiff how many
surgeries have you had and how many will
you have to have in the future
well i'm on surgery number three um
we think potentially another one maybe
two
or three the swelling can take a year to
go down
i'd say i'm probably like 10 or 15 of
the strength
that i used to have buddy where does
this leave you as far as
making cakes in the future because
you're not just a cake
baker you're an artist honestly kim
i don't know how much i'm going to be
able to
do i might be like a boxer who's got the
heart but ain't got the tools anymore
whether i have to do it left-handed at
30
i'm gonna try to do it with all my heart
and the only time will tell
wow buddy to hear you say that it sent
shivers through my body i mean have you
you've thought about that i'm not ready
to be on the sidelines yet
you guys are shooting a recovery special
for tlc
have you or did you go back in that
bowling alley yet i actually went for
the first time with the camera crew last
week it was emotional
buddy's road to recovery special airs
next month on tlc
this sunday night his new holiday series
premieres on the food network
let's talk about buddy versus christmas
and it's interesting because it's the
last thing you filmed before you got
hurt you know kev
honestly i remember finishing filming
that show coming home to my wife
and saying lee these were like some of
the best cakes i ever did in my life
holy cow look at what we did it's hard
to keep someone like me down
let's just say i appreciate things so
much more
you